bonjour et c'est là la situation
sanitaire inquiète donc dans certaines
régions de france
le conseil de défense va bien sûr abordé
est cette question ce conseil de défense
qu'en est-il précisément estelle et bien
écoutez à magalas exécutif redoute
l'arrivée d'une troisième vague de kobe
de 19 sur le territoire alors vous
l'avez dit un nouveau conseil à de
défense est donc convoqué ce mardi on ne
sait pas encore s il débouchera sur de
nouvelles mesures alors le conseil de
défense c'est un dispositif qui s'est
imposé comme l'un des principaux outils
pour acter notamment les mesures prises
pour tenter d'endiguer à l'épidémie sur
le territoire tout au long de cette
crise sanitaire
pour information depuis le début de
cette crise le conseil de défense s'est
réuni au moins une quarantaine de fois
alors vous vous en doutez un ce
dispositif ne date pas d'hier puisque sa
création remonte à l'année à 1958 en
voilà pour l'anecdote alors aujourd'hui
plusieurs responsables politiques mais
aussi des hauts fonctionnaires et des
spécialistes vont donc se réunir autour
être des manuels macron tous autour de
la table sont tenus au secret défense
estelle ses conseils de défense ont été
vivement critiquées dans l'opposition
oui à droite comme à gauche que ce soit
l a france insoumise europe ecologie les
verts ou encore lé république avant tous
ils sont allés à de leurs petites
phrases c'est ce qui est pointée du
doigt en c1 l'opacité autour de ces
réunions mais aussi une certaine
concentration des pouvoirs je propose
d'écouter ces quelques réactions ce qui
me gêne c'est que ce conseil de défense
c'est sous la coupe du secret défense
il n'y a donc aucun compte rendu de ce
qui s'y dit et il y à leur
irresponsabilité pénale
macron décide seul avec quelques
conseillers le conseil de défense c'est
ce qui a remplacé le conseil des
ministres c'est ça cela donne le
sentiment que le conseil des ministres
n'est plus là et que c'est maintenant le
conseil de défense qui décide de tout il
y à des institutions des instances les
respecter c'est mieux voilà vous l'aurez
compris contrairement au conseil des
ministres aucun compte rendu ou à
l'ordre du jour
sont rendues publiques lors d'un conseil
de défense et on a quand même une petite
idée estelle des discussions qui vont se
tenir aujourd'hui puisque trois régions
inquiète particulièrement
exactement la gagner il s'agit à des
alpes maritimes de la bourgogne franche
comté et du grand s prenons par exemple
la lorraine le maire ps de lens il ya un
petit peu tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
cette semaine il s'est dit très inquiet
de la situation à l'hôpital une
situation qu'il juge très tendue ce sont
ses mots flaba selon lui la circulation
du virus s est accélérée depuis quinze
jours trois semaines c'est notamment ce
qu'il a indiqué à nos confrères de
france info l'élu qui a plaidé pour un
confinement locale et puis même son de
cloche à nice en le maire 1 christian
estrosi a demandé un renforcement des
mesures restrictives il s'est d'ailleurs
entretenu avec olivier aveyron il
souhaite aussi que la campagne de
vaccination débute tout de suite dans la
région olivier ferrand de son côté
ministre de la santé donc qui a laissé
la porte ouverte en troisième
confinement si la situation devait
s'aggraver c'est en tout cas ce qu'il a
confié à nos confrères du jdd
merci beaucoup estelle pour toutes ces
précisions suivra bien évidemment ce
conseil de défense sur rt france